y para toda la información de salud nos
acompaña nuestra periodista más romeros
mar bienvenida de nuevo acá
y empecemos con una noticia bastante
positiva para romper el negativismo que
generalmente tenemos porque hay
resultados esperanzadores con una nueva
vacuna contra la malaria así es podemos
empezar con estas buenas noticias no
siempre damos malas noticias tampoco
aquí en salud aunque estemos
acostumbrados a reportar sobre kobe
sobre viruela del mono no es una vacuna
desarrollada por la universidad de
oxford que ya venía estudiando se desde
hace unos años pero ahora se ha
publicado en the lancet un nuevo estudio
con resultados todavía más prometedores
que sobre todo aseguran pues que es una
vacuna eficaz y que es una vacuna segura
el estudio es hecho con 409 niños entre
15 y 17 meses de edad todos en burkina
faso y se ha seguido durante un año por
eso se tiene esta seguridad seguridad de
que la vacuna pues no tiene efectos
secundarios nocivos funciona intentando
interceptar el parásito que provoca la
malaria en su primera fase del ciclo
vital para que no llegue al hígado que
es desde donde este parásito se instala
y ataca
el resto del cuerpo en cuanto a la
eficacia es donde llegan las mejores
noticias vamos a ver uno de los gráficos
que publicaron también en the lancet en
este diario científico entonces vemos
bueno básicamente nos indican dos tipos
de grupos tenemos la línea verde es la
que las personas que refieren un placebo
es decir las personas que no han sido
vacunadas la línea azul es las que
recibieron una dosis menor de la vacuna
y la línea roja son los que recibieron
una dosis alta de la vacuna entonces
aquí nos muestran los casos acumulados
de malaria a lo largo de más de un año
en este todos en todos estos grupos
distintos de vacunación como lo podemos
interpretar pues este vacío que existe
entre la línea verde y la línea roja
significa todos esos casos de malaria
que esta vacuna ha podido evitar menos
hospitalizaciones menos muertes menos
transfusiones de sangre y sobre todo eso
menos afectaciones entre los niños que
son los principales afectados por esta
enfermedad pues ojalá terminemos con
mejores noticias aún pero hace casi un
año la oms se anunció que respaldó otra
vacuna contra la malaria como se
comparan
es fue en octubre de 2021 una noticia
histórica porque la primera que recibía
este respaldo de la organización mundial
de la salud entonces digamos que
teniendo en cuenta que la malaria es una
enfermedad que mata más de 400 nueve mil
personas al año especialmente en el
continente africano cualquier
herramienta va a ser bienvenida entonces
la vacuna está que se hizo famosa el año
pasado se llama mosquirix desde la
farmacéutica gsk no podemos empezar la
comparación a sin decir que la primera
está demos clic se ha aplicado en planes
piloto a gran escala tiene unos estudios
mucho más completos muchos más años de
investigación mientras que la otra pues
todavía estamos en fase 2 de estudio con
409 409 perdón sujetos de estudio
entonces ahí salvando esas distancias es
que tenemos que dar el resto de
información con esa precaución una la
primera en la que ya existe se tiene una
protección entre 40 por ciento sesenta
por ciento dependiendo de en qué momento
de la temporada de malaria digamos se
aplique la otra tiene un 80 por ciento
de protección como decíamos resultados
esperanzadores aunque pueden estar
todavía un poco inflados precisamente
por ese timing de cuando se aplicó la
vacuna y también pues la pequeña muestra
del estudio 1 dicen que solo pueden
provocar pueden producir 15 millones de
dosis anuales porque necesitan más apoyo
para poder producir más las otras
millones de dosis anuales esto también
es muy positivo con una asociación con
el serum institute de india por cierto y
pues todas el final entre una y otra
cosa son cuatro dosis eso significa que
va a requerir realmente mucha voluntad
internacional porque una esquema de
inmunización de cuatro dosis es difícil
de aplicar entonces pues bueno todo el
esfuerzo detrás de esta inmunización
contra contra la malaria y para hablemos
de la viruela del mono en américa buenas
noticias o no pues más o menos no lo
pensé ayer la organización panamericana
de la salud dijo que habían visto un
descenso leve de los casos aunque
todavía era muy temprano para cantar
victoria para decir que esa tendencia
era clara en todo el continente 30.000
casos los países con más casos en
estados unidos canadá brasil y perú y
siguen reportándose esa tendencia de que
el mayor contagios entre hombres que
tienen sexo con hombres sin significar
eso que no todo el mundo que se exponga
a este virus pueda estar pueda exponerse
al contagio entonces también además
dijeron un llamado a una comunicación
de prejuicios para que todo el mundo sin
tener el estigma pueda acercarse a los
puestos de salud a buscar ayuda a
vacunarse bueno yo insisto podemos
terminar con una buena noticia
relativamente escuchemos precisamente
hablando de vacunas lo que decía la pps
el fondo rotatorio de la ops para
vacunas asegura dosis como varían
nórdica convirtiéndonos en la primera
región de la oms y en poner vacunas
contra la viruela del mono a disposición
de los estados miembros de las turbas
states
23 vehementemente pero las dosis siguen
limitadas así que la ope se recomienda
priorizar las vacunas para grupos de
alto riesgo
jair pérez caps estamos hablando de
100.000 dosis de vacunas las que
asegurada la bps para países en el
riesgo sin embargo como decían buenas
noticias relativas porque estas dosis
siguen siendo muy escasas y como eeuu ha
comprado ya la mayoría gracias mal por
toda la información y nosotros